Speaker 1: Let's go.
Next.
I'm told that Scottish Scott from Scotland
has fixed his problems.
Scottish?
Scott, you're back.
What's going on?
Speaker 3: Hey, David, can you hear me?
Speaker 1: Yes, I can.
Speaker 2: Oh, fantastic.
Yeah, sorry about that.
I just saw your interview on YouTube, and
so I put down with this card, you can get
up and running and.
Yeah, I wasn't quite used to getting to work
and know it.
I knew myself.
Speaker 1: Are you sure you're really Scottish?
Speaker 2: What makes you say that?
Speaker 1: No, I'm kidding.
I'm kidding.
Go ahead.
What's on your mind?
Speaker 2: The obvious.
Yeah.
I'm just really looking forward to the the
final hearing of the January 6th committee
tomorrow.
I just wondered what you're thinking in anticipation
of, like, who's going to be there and what
sort of testimony we might expect and how
the Trumpists at large may sort of respond
to that.
Speaker 1: Well, unfortunately, because this
is the Friday show, that hearing was last
night.
And I know that you've been in a coma for
48 hours, so you wouldn't know that.
But I believe what happened Slash is expected
is that Donald Trump's former deputy national
security adviser will testify.
Donald Trump's attorney, a White House attorney,
pat cipollone is expected slash did testify
and i am looking forward to slash really enjoyed
it last night, if you understand what i'm
saying.
Speaker 2: Get your house.
And let's just say that all the TV wires melted
yesterday due to all these things a lot of
students in the UK do so well anyway.
Speaker 1: Isn't it like three days earlier
in Scotland or something like that?
Speaker 2: Three days earlier.
Speaker 1: That's why you just haven't gotten
the hearing yet.
Speaker 2: Yeah.
Yeah, we're actually talking, traveling, and
I can see into your future.
Thank you for.
No, no.
See, you made a video earlier about the what
was it the reaction from Trump supporters
to those become invited by Merrick Garland
or whomever.
And I, if I remember correctly, you saw the
that he could potentially be among his strongest
cult followers.
A really strong, violent reaction.
Yes.
And I'm not so sure.
I think I think, yes, there will be a certain
violent reaction.
But in terms of like mass protests of thousands
of people all gathering together, I just get
the impression that, A, there are two.
Shattered the shrapnel, I should say, at the
moment.
And they're just too far spread and they can't
organize themselves well enough and be I don't
know I just.
Do you think are that far gone?
The if.
He were to be indicted.
People would see that as, oh, they're and
they're lying is fake news, etc. or would
always be like a wake up call for a lot of
homes.
Oh, no.
Brainwash?
Speaker 1: No.
The cultists would say that it's all a political
witch hunt.
They would say this is an outrage.
And we I think you're right.
They wouldn't do like mass peaceful protests.
You would just have these small violent cells
going completely berserk.
Scott, I got to run.
I appreciate the call and hearing about all
of it.